ACCOUNTABILITY.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
THE FALLOUT FROM THAT CALAMITOUS
MUELLER TESTIMONY CONTINUE TO
REVERBERATE TODAY AND THE
QUESTIONS KEEP MOUNTING.
HOW IS A MAN WHO'S OBVIOUSLY SO
DETACHED FROM KEY ASPECTS OF THE
CASE EVER ALLOWED TO RUN THE
INVESTIGATION?
WHY DIDN'T THEY AND MAKE THE
INVESTIGATION WHEN THEY REALIZED
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION OR
CONSPIRACY TO
HOW COULD MUELLER NOT KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT FUSION GPS?
AND WHY WASN'T THE FISA COURT
FULLY INFORMED ABOUT THE ORIGINS
OF THE DOSSIER?
HOW DID TRUMP HATING PARTISANS
MANAGE TO BECOME KEY PLAYERS ON
MUELLER'S TEAM?
WHY DO ELITES ALWAYS SEEM TO GET
AWAY WITH THE ABUSE OF POWER
WHEN CONSERVATIVES LIKE TRUMP
ARE DRAGGED THROUGH THE MUD FOR
SOMETHING HE DIDN'T EVEN DO?
WELL, AS FOR THE LAST QUESTION,
THE ELITES OF BOTH PARTIES,
LET'S FACE IT, HAVE A LOT TO
ANSWER FOR.
IT'S UP TO US TO HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE.
THIS KIND OF THING DOESN'T
HAPPEN EVER AGAIN TO ANY
PRESIDENT OR FRANKLY ANY
AMERICAN CITIZEN.
SO THAT NO ONE IS SUBJECTED TO
DEFAMATION OR SADDLED WITH
MASSIVE LEGAL BILLS, OR HAS HIS
OR HER ENTIRE LIFE'S WORK, IN
THIS CASE, HIS ENTIRE
PRESIDENCY, PUT IN JEOPARDY.
THE FACT IS THE SO-CALLED ELITES
HAVE BEEN FAILING US FOR DECADE
DECADES.
AND TRUMP, REMEMBER, CALLED THEM
ALL OUT IN 2016.
I DO NOT THINK THEY EVER FORGAVE
HIM.
ELITES HAVE BEEN WRONG ABOUT
MAJOR HISTORY AUTHORING ISSUES.
UNDER FORMER FED CHAIR ALAN
GREENSPAN, THEY EVEN CALLED HIM
THE MAESTRO.
HE PRESIDED OVER THE HOUSING
BUBBLE AND ALONG WITH
BILL CLINTON HE THOUGHT IT WAS
JUST PEACHY TO ALLOW CHINA INTO
THE WORLD TRADE ORGANIZATION.
>> PERMANENT NORMAL TRADE
RELATIONS WITH CHINA WILL HAVE
PROFOUND IMPLICATIONS FOR THE
FREE WORLD'S TRADING SYSTEM AND
THE LONG-TERM GROWTH POTENTIAL
OF THE AMERICAN ECONOMY.
>> Laura: REMEMBER, FOLKS,
FROM THE BUSH YEARS COMPILE
BEFORE IT'S?
HE WAS THE ARCHITECT OF THE IRAQ
WAR.
HE ALSO GOT TRUMP WRONG TOO.
>> IS THERE A REASON YOU'RE
PICKING CLINTON OVER TRUMP?
>> I FIND IT INCREDIBLY
DISAPPOINTING WHEN THE COUNTRY
NEEDS TO COME TOGETHER THAT WE
HAVE TWO MAJOR PARTY CANDIDATES
WHO ENJOY SO LITTLE CONFIDENCE
IN THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Laura: [CACKLING]
THAT'S FUNNY.
CONFIDENCE IN THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE?
ACCORDING TO A PEW RESEARCH POLL
BY 2008, ONLY 38% OF THE COUNTRY
THOUGHT THAT THE DECISION TO
INVADE IRAQ WAS THE RIGHT
DECISION.
THAT HELPED ELECT BARACK OBAMA.
AS FOR OBAMA, HE PLEDGED INTO
BRING IN A NEW TEAM OF PRO-S,
THE ELITE OF THE ELITE WHO WOULD
SHOW EVERYONE HOW GOVERNANCE IS
REALLY DONE.
INSTEAD, HE BROUGHT US ANEMIC
GROWTH, THE IRAN DEAL, AND AN
OBAMACARE WEBSITE THAT DIDN'T
EVEN WORK.
>> DID YOU TRY SIGNING ON THE
SITE YOURSELF?
I HAVE CREATED AN ACCOUNT ON THE
SIGHT.
I HAVE NOT TRIED SIGNING UP
BECAUSE I HAVE INSURANCE.
>> WHAT DID YOU THINK OF IT?
>> CERTAINLY ARE SOME CHALLENGES
THAT COULD BE SMOOTHER, COULD BE
EASIER TO ACCESS, THAT'S REALLY
WHAT WE ARE WORKING ON.
NOBODY SAYS THE SITE IS WORKING
THE WAY WE WANT IT TO.
>> Laura: WAIT A SECOND.
I THOUGHT THEY WERE GOING TO BE
THE SMARTEST PEOPLE EVER.
AND YESTERDAY, WE WERE REMINDED
THAT THE AMERICAN TAXPAYERS
SPEND $34 MILLION FOR AN
INVESTIGATION THAT COULD'VE BEEN
EASILY EASILY HANDLED BY THE
REGULAR LINE PROSECUTORS AT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
AN INVESTIGATION LED BY A MAN
WHO WAS CLEARLY PAST HIS PRIME,
SO PAST HIS PRIME THAT HE DIDN'T
EVEN BOTHER DOING A CONFLICT
CHECK ON THE TEAM HE ASSEMBLED.
>> ANDREW WEISSMANN ATTENDED
HILLARY CLINTON'S ELECTION
PARTY.
DID YOU KNOW THAT BEFORE
AFTER --
>> I DON'T KNOW WHEN I FOUND
THAT OUT.
>> ARE YOU AWARE GENIE DEAN REP
IS IN HILLARY CLINTON
ORIGINATING FROM HILLARY
CLINTON'S TIME FROM SECULAR
STATE?
>> DID YOU KNOW THAT BEFORE --
>> NO.
>> Laura: A FIRST-YEAR
ASSOCIATE AT PRETTY MUCH ANY LAW
FIRM KNOWS THAT THE MERE
APPEARANCE OF BIAS OR CONFLICT
IS OFTEN ENOUGH TO REQUIRE
RECUSAL FROM ANY CASE.
IN THE SITUATION, WITH THE
STAKES SO HIGH, THIS WAS OF
PARAMOUNT IMPORTANCE.
BY THE WAY, EACH LAWYER ON
MUELLER'S TEAM HAD AN
AFFIRMATIVE LEGAL OBLIGATION
UNDER THE ETHICS RULES TO
CONSIDER THEIR OWN ANTI-TRUMP
BIAS.
TO DECLINE THE OFFER TO WORK ON
THE RUSSIAN COLLUSION
INVESTIGATION GIVEN THEIR PAST
CONNECTIONS TO THE DEMOCRATS.
MY FRIENDS, REPUBLICANS MUST
HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE AND GET
REAL ANSWERS AS TO WHY THIS TEAM
WAS ALLOWED TO OPERATE OUTSIDE
THE CODE OF PROFESSIONAL